How do we find the inverse of Matrix A here?
It's a 3X3 matrix this time.
The formula for A inverse that we saw in the previous lesson
is valid for all square Matrices.
It's equal to one over the determinant of 'A',
multiplied by the adjoin of 'A'.
No elementary operations needed!
The condition states that the determinant of 'A' must not be equal to zero.
That's because the denominator cannot be equal to zero.
If the determinant of 'A' is zero,
then we can say that the inverse of Matrix A does not exist.
So that's the first thing we should do. We find the determinant of 'A'.
We can have the first row as the reference,
because we've already solved innumerable determinant problems,
let's go through this quickly.
The Element two will be multiplied with this determinant to get this.
Two multiplied with 1 times 0, minus 2 times 1.
The next element is 'minus 1', we get this.
Minus because we are multiplying this product with 'minus 1' raised to 1 plus 2.
The last element for the first row is 0.
Because it's 0 it doesn't matter what it's multiplied with.
The product will always be 0.
This will be the value of the determinant.
This part in the brackets will equal 0 minus 2. Which equals 'minus 2.'
2 times 'minus 2' will equal minus 4.
What about the second product?
Inside the brackets we have '0 minus 2' which equals 'minus 2.'
1 times 'minus 2', is 'minus 2.' And this product is 0.
'Minus 4' 'minus 2', will equal 'minus 6'.
We have the determinant now.
It's 'minus 6.' As it's not equal to 0
we can say that it's non singular.
The inverse of this Matrix exists.
So we can move on to finding the adjoint of A now.
To find the adjoint we first find the matrix of co-factors of each of the elements,
and then find the transpose of that Matrix.
So let's find the co-factors of each of the elements now.
The first element is two.
Its co-factor will equal 'minus 1' raised to 1 plus 1, times its minor.
Its minor is the determinant of what's left
after excluding its row and column.
So the co-factor will equal 1 multiplied by 0 minus 2, 'minus 2.'
The co-factor of this 2, is 'minus 2.'
Now we come to the co-factor of 'minus 1.' It will equal
'minus 1' raised to 1 Plus 2, times 0, times 0 minus 2, times 1.
'Minus 1' times 'minus 2' is 2.
Similarly we get the co factor of 0 as 'minus 1.'
Now please pause the video take your time
and solve for the remaining 6 co- factors.
These are the six remaining co-factors.
This transpose will give us the adjoint of Matrix A.
To find the transpose, we interchange the rows and the columns.
The first row will become the first column
'minus 2', 2, 'minus 1.'
The second row will be the second column.
0, 0, 'minus 3'.
And lastly the third Row will become the third column.
'minus 2', 'Minus 4', 2.
Now we have the adjoint as well.
And because we have both we can find A inverse now.
Let's write it here.
1 over determinant of A will be 1 over 'minus 6.'
We multiply this with the adjoint of 'A'.
What will this be equal to?
This is the adjoint. To get this
we multiply this scalier with each element of the adjoint.
1 over 'minus 6' times 'minus 2', will equal 1 over 3.
1 over 'minus 6' times 0, will equal 0.
1 over 'minus 6' times 'minus 2' will equal 1 over 3 again.
And like always, I want you to find the remaining six elements.
Remember, we need to multiply each of the elements with this scalar.
These are the six elements you should have got.
This is 'A' inverse. We found it using this formula.
So this was pretty long,
but still faster than using an elementary operation.
Remember the formula.
'A' inverse is equal to 1 over the determinant of 'A' times the adjoint of 'A'.